Okay. So, uh, hello everyone. I'm Exenia
Montruidu. My friends call me Dr. X. I
have a very long last name. Um, and I'm
a data scientist. I'm not a security
person. Uh, don't hold this against me.
Uh, but I've been doing security data
science for about 15 years. So, I love
the area. Um, and I want to talk about a
question that has been torturing me for
a while. I work for an M managed
detection and response uh, company,
Expel. Uh, and I've done a lot of um,
predictive modeling, traditional ML
modeling in my lifetime. Uh, and these
predictive models can really uh, figure
out boundaries. uh but I was always
wondering if generative models can do
that and especially for uh security
applications and you can see there's a
lot of differences between the two um
and for that um a big deal for us is
classification
uh classifying bad from good or even the
nuances of classification multiple
classes like benign but you know maybe
something so possibly benign multiclass
classification So um there's a lot of
reasons to classify insecurity. I mean I
hope I don't have to convince you much
that uh there's plenty of reasons to
classify malicious from abnormal
behavior emails. Uh but also in our case
uh it's a lot about prioritizing
triaging and all that. So um I did uh
some research um and compared um
language models as classifiers uh with
um a traditional ML model. So WM w uh
the traditional ML model wins. It's the
uh it's the the bar that is the highest
in precision recall. It it's the most
sensitive to find evil and also uh the
the most uh precise. Uh however um
language models are zeroot classifiers.
My uh my data uh was networking uh data
and very well-labeled data. So there was
no doubt in the evaluation. Uh and zero
shot means that I don't need to train
them. I just you know prompt them and
they classify. So so that's very
promising. Um and um even though it
doesn't win uh it could get better. uh
now it could get better with
fine-tuning. So I really set up the
models for something the language models
for something difficult uh because these
were networking data also so they could
be better in classifying let's say
emails. So final thoughts and I do plan
I have actually some research in LLM and
ML ensembles. Uh so final thought and
there's a lot of architectures over
there uh that I've looked at but I'm
thinking about some some combination uh
ensemble. So uh so uh so you may see me
in another conference but I also uh have
experimented with um specialized
embeddings. Uh sometimes they win uh
sometimes they don't. Uh so you could
have a very good generalist model uh
with generalized embeddings that does
better believe it or not. Uh and that's
about it. I would love to talk much more
about this. I prepared this for kind of
five minutes, but if you have questions,
you can also check my website uh about
this. And I'd love to talk about uh if
you have any ideas uh or are working in
the in this uh kind of area. Thank you.
All right. Does anyone have a question?
Please just put your hand up. Perfect.
Uh thanks. What was the input for your
LLM classifier?
>> So so the input is very interesting
because it's not manage detection and
response. I'm doing this right now. It's
not alerts. Uh the input was packet
captures uh for which I did very careful
feature engineering. Uh so um so packet
captures are difficult for a language
model. again it's not text. Uh so uh so
I did some feature engineering with you
know protocol or payload if I if I had
something that was not encrypted uh or
timelines and all that and I kind of I
kind of guided uh the model with the
zero shot. So the only part that was
there was some feature engineering. So I
think this is the toughest po problem
for a model to be a classifier and I've
experimented with emails for example uh
and they do much better because text uh
but it's it's worth exploring because we
hear it a lot in in our industry like oh
just give it to a language model it's
going to classify it it's going to find
evil it's like no for networking it
won't so so yes so uh so that's uh that
was the input it was the mai botnet um
That's why I'm saying it's very well
labeled. It's a known attack and there
was very good data of benign activity
too. So, so yeah, I didn't want to have
any doubts on the labeling.
>> So, thank you. That was a great
question.
>> All right. Anyone else? Oh, right behind
me.
>> So, you mentioned that uh like with
email data, the LLM as a judge was
likely to be better or better than it
was um for classification. Do you think
there's a like a data set or a type of
classification thatation that be better
than a traditional machine learning
model? It's like a high context size or
like does it stop at emails or is there
is there other areas of text where it
might be better? I'm curious.
>> So this is a really good question and
I'll give you a sneak preview of the
research. So I have done actually
research with multiple uh fishing data
sets from hugging phase uh with a
traditional XG boost model which is very
good with very good feature engineering
because emails okay it's it's a known
problem uh and then I did a router
experiment uh so the router is like oh
let's give this to an exibboost model
first and classify and then give it to
the LLM. So the combination of LLM and
traditional did better. Uh I have not
had success with just the LLM doing
better but maybe somebody will over
here. So uh so yes so I've also
experimented with cloud opus uh four 4.6
six um and uh classifying with nothing.
And again it did better with a lower
data set uh like if you gave it 100
samples because it takes so long for
this model to finish. uh and um but but
when I gave more uh uh when I gave
additional data actually believe it or
not uh anthropic it doesn't do as well
in classification uh which again it's
normal there's you know there's a reason
for that okay so traditional models can
find those boundaries and LLMs were not
meant uh for that so good question I can
talk for an hour about this
>> well thank you very